the upx tower built by bowman and  associates has been designed to be one  of these safest buildings on the market  today  that means a lot coming from a  structural engineer of your caliber yeah  we really need to see our parents it's  really quite interesting 60th floor on  this way hey I'm a little worried here  my power consumption just jumped up to  75 percent fire alarm do we care the  building now they're tearing the  building you're in the building they're  stuck in an elevator  what floor I don't know we have a major  gas leak the entire building could blow  at any moment  my mom and I are gonna get you out of  there just stay put okay everything's  gonna be fine  they're more than 60 stories tall  my advice is limited in the way to deal  with my sisters  [Music]  I can't do it on my own  they're around the 28th floor only show  I'm sure  my life isn't that thrilling  [Music]  you  you